uh great experience and he can do a bunch of
things offensively now a shot that goes off the
post as kachuck was looking for a deflection out
front and now this building has come to life after
that a little bit more than 3 minutes gone by
here in the first period Ottawa now with a chance
getting it up front Anderson with a big save
now a long drive from Zu is deflected the score
Aram Zub put the shot through but it's Ottawa
getting a tip out in front early in this one
you Joseph and a one- nothing lead for Ottawa
now off the rush really an extension of the
power play Anderson with a big time save and
you had two layers on the way in getting the
puck to the net chartier was above the crease
and Joseph well I think has been a another
save by Anderson one pass too many trying
to connect the dots here's yes foros in on
Corp pasalo back in a penalty coming up is Corp
pasalo robs F but a penalty shot will be awarded
teric opportunity the criteria in the clear
yes number a reasonable scoring opportunity
going to be clutch here with a penalty shot
here comes fost in on Corp pasalo dancing
with it he's shot Corp makes the [Applause]
save a popular shot location is try to get the
goenda though will take the puck away from warlo
and now possible two-on-one for centers storming
in Got Hand chance and a big save Again by
Anderson pinches or not safety valve support
at the offensive Blue Line you're going to pay a
real price against Ottawa and Carolina's been up
against a couple of times times with a defenseman
it represents a ton of trust and belief from AO
to the hurricanes and the Hurricanes to AO now
Martin throws it out in front Rolling Puck and
unable to get the settle for that was fost as he
had another glorious opportunity played inspiring
hockey I mean you can make an argument as heavy
as he plays when you lost fetch nikov you lost
patch ready you still go to the conference fin
a lose Terin for a lot of it not in front for
stor but solo somehow got across and focus on the
fact that you might be playing a few less minutes
but higher quality minutes it's a quality problem
to have suffice to say and we're underway here in
the second period AO side of the net bunny back
to AO up top it's D'Angelo AO with it spreading
it out in front Bing works his way through he's
welcome to Carolina Michael Bunning a power play
goal we're tied at one [Music] he's always had
the ability to score goals Michael bonting as a
net front but also a pop out guy and this was a
goal scorer's goal because it required patience
with the outstretched legs and stick of Corpus
solo to hold hold and even hold some more before
he could find the lower portion of the net to tie
the game and score the first goal located in pre
agency you are the model of consistency somewh
disagree now a chance for a out in front and
Anderson comes up with his biggest save of this
game on his left cheek and as that was going on
now that creates an opportunity for Ottawa really
good Puck movement from kachuck and when I say
catapult he'll get it back for pesing pesi NES
back for peshi his Drive rockets off the ends
chance comes across ré that that misses the net
peshi keeps it in his Drive deflected over the
top of the net Oh Carolina is swarming right
now across for terid he scores Carolina takes
the 2-1 lead it's turbo time in [Music] Raleigh
that Relentless we will just keep on coming for
check of Carolina has started to really illustrate
itself here in this period sh Shay had jumped in
from the Blue Line nearly scored and stayed on the
attack they just protected the puck beautifully
Tera very cerebrally backed off I love that deep
voice by huge Caniac Scotty MCC can I tell you
a really quick story last June he was playing a
concert on a Saturday night in Michigan I played
golf with him in the morning and a buddy that I
was playing with offered him a really nice cigar
and he said Scotty you smoke a cigar in a night
you're going to perform he said heck yeah I do
might be the key to that deep voice of the great
Scotty mccy Martin setting up stall up FRS give
that man a cigar Carolina Goes Up 3 to one Jordan
stalls first of the year opening night never gets
old because the smile on Jordan stalls face played
his first opening night in October 2006 it says at
all Puck support between Martin can stall in
the trenches Martin puts it in a place that a
penetrating stall can receive it with his range
go forehand backhand consistent every night the
32-year-old has the puff now he sweeps it across
Mason drops it back for orloff his shot doesn't
get through as he's fronted by Joseph good play
by Joseph and now Ottawa trying to create an odman
rush out in front go score shorthanded Parker
Kelly gets to the slot and that's a short-handed
goal for Ottawa and it's a one-goal game here in
Carolina sure to get it by that first guy and then
he gambled on the passing Lane he put his stick
down one way and a really smart play by Joseph to
recognize where orof was going to try to deny the
passing Lane and go to the vacant Lane to Kell it
all of a sudden it's a one-goal game it's a bit of
a freebie all credit to Bost keeps it in martinook
his pass detected by kachuck that'll be slapped
Away by peshi but storming right back in to
score Tim STS showing why he's the third
overall pick in 2020 ties this game in
three Chuck just oh you know that puck R knows
that puck hit the linesman that is a really
unfortunate bounce that puck hit the linesman
it looked like in the newal Zone and Ottawa
takes advantage Tola 90 points last year even
with stall trying to work the pot free but it's
Ottawa out to be stolen good pickpocket there from
Martin sta we'll get it to stall the fost this
line creating a chance and she scores top of the
circle Brady Shay puts Carolina back in the lead
I mean just a stellar for check and you
think it's going to be over but it's not
tracking back with a purpose of all purposes
is martinook tries to find stall I think it
hits escap retrieval for fost puts it on a team
for Brady Shay look at how flat that thing is
and Brady uses the screen to his Advantage a
bit unorthodox report pasalo cuz he actually
looked like he tried to lines up his man
and that creates a turnover for coachi he
flutters one into the Auto Zone Jarvis with it
7 seconds left in this PK sled with it he scores
shorthanded Oh Carolina come across and
take a 5-3 lead what a short-handed hit
by Jarvis and all of a sudden you're in
the attacking Zone poing YY draws two
players and Mike Jacob slaven has changed
his curve this year he's put a little bit
more curve to get the puck elevation and
it pays off for him in game one to go ping
short side POS 9 seconds left Carolina
will open up with another win yet again